- [David] Hello, grammarians.
Today I wanna talk about
the concept of irony,
which is a very difficult
concept to nail down
because it means so many things.
But let's begin with the
best definition I can muster,
which is that irony is
the difference between
expectation and result.
Now, this contains a lot within it.
So, that means that irony is
not only the engine of
surprise, but also jokes.
All jokes in English function
on this engine of the difference
between expectation and result.
You expect to hear one thing
and then a joke plays
with your expectations.
There's nothing less funny than
explaining why things are funny.
But this is why things are funny.
So, today we're gonna talk about
three different kinds of irony.
And I'm going to give
you an example of each.
Now, the first kind is
called situational irony.
In situational irony, everyone is aware
of the discrepancy of the difference
between expectation and result.
And a really classic example of this is
the O. Henry short story
The Gift of the Magi.
And it's about a couple who are very poor,
but who love each other very much.
And each one wants to get the other
a really nice Christmas present.
The man has a very lovely watch
and the woman has really lovely long hair.
And, unbeknownst to the other,
the woman buys her husband a watch chain
and the man buys his wife a comb.
But, in order to do that,
he sells his watch to buy her the comb
and, in order to buy him the watch chain,
the woman sells her hair.
And so, they give each other
gifts that are now useless.
This watch chain and this comb.
For the hair that isn't there
and the watch that isn't there.
And the irony is that
they are now aware that
the lengths that they
went to for the other
kind of ruined each other's gifts.
That's situational irony.
It's kind of a happy ending,
'cause it proves stuff is just stuff
and they love each other very much.
That's situational irony.
Everyone is aware of the discrepancy.
Irony variant number two
is called dramatic irony.
This means that there's
an unevenly distributed
awareness of the difference.
Specifically, that there's an audience.
So, this is the sort of thing that
really only comes into play in
fiction or in dramatic work.
So, we're talking about a
play or a movie or whatever.
So, let's say we've got a play.
Here's our stage.
Here's our audience down here.
We have one character here, character A,
who really doesn't like bears
and is talking about if
he ever meets a bear,
he's probably gonna punch
that bear right in the face.
And here is character B, who is a bear,
but is a bear in disguise
wearing a hat and a tie.
Now, character B knows
that character B is a bear.
The audience knows that
character B is a bear.
Character A is unaware.
So, we have this unevenly
distributed awareness
of the difference between
expectation and result.
Character A expects that
character B is not a bear.
But character B and the audience
knows that the opposite is true.
That's dramatic irony.
Now, the third kind of irony
we're going to talk about today
is called verbal irony.
So, the irony of words.
And this one's a little different,
because verbal irony is the difference
between a stated meaning
and an actual meaning.
And this means that it can
come in a couple of flavors.
The most notable, and
perhaps the most confusing,
is called sarcasm.
And sarcasm is when you say a thing,
but it actually ends up meaning
something quite different,
usually the opposite.
So, let's say an anvil,
very heavy metal object,
falls on my foot, breaks my foot.
I am in extraordinary pain.
If you asked me how I was doing
and I wanted to use sarcasm,
I would say something
like, "Oh, I'm just great."
And I'm signaling, with
my tone and also context,
to indicate that the opposite is true.
To say, "I'm actually terrible.
My foot is broken."
That's sarcasm.
Now, related to sarcasm is the pun,
which is usually a joke that
plays on multiple meanings.
So, again, let's take this case.
Let's say my foot was crushed by an anvil
You ask me how I'm doing.
I would say, "I'm feeling
a little flat today."
No, not a great joke, sure.
But what I'm trying to express is that
I am both playing on the
notion that I don't feel well,
I feel a little flat,
and that my foot has been
squished by a heavy object,
literally rendering it flat.
That's what a pun is.
And, again, I recognize
that, by explaining the joke,
I have made the joke unfunny.
I apologize.
So, to review, let's put
all of these together
into one giant ironic situation.
So, let's say you're watching
a sitcom on television.
And this sitcom takes place
in someone's apartment
and that apartment has a
thing called a Murphy bed.
Now, what a Murphy bed is is a bed that
folds up into the wall to save
space in a small apartment.
It's got this little handle up here.
You grab it, you pull it down,
it becomes just a regular bed.
Otherwise, it's kept
folded up into the wall.
So, let's say we're watching a sitcom
that takes place in a small
apartment that has a Murphy bed.
Let's say that our main
character has just come home
from the airport with her visiting cousin.
So, again, this is a sitcom.
This is all happening on your television.
So, this is all inside the frame.
Now, unbeknownst to our
protagonist, let's call her Anna,
and her cousin, let's call her Bella,
a lion has crawled into the Murphy bed
while the two of them were out.
I promise this has a point.
So, hidden behind this wall
is a lion on top of this bed.
Now, ignorant of all of this,
Bella asks her cousin "Is
the Murphy bed comfortable?"
To which Anna replies "Yeah.
It's perfect for lyin' on."
I think you see where I'm going here.
So, dramatic irony.
We, the audience on the
other side of the screen,
are aware that this entire that
this entire time there's a
lion hiding in the Murphy bed.
We know this.
Anna and Bella do not.
Bella asks if the bed is comfortable.
Anna assures her that it is.
We know, as the audience, it is not.
There is a dangerous
savanna predator in the bed.
That's dramatic irony.
Situational irony, when they
pull that Murphy bed down
and expose the lion,
they will see the difference between
these expectations and this result.
And that is situational irony.
You thought one thing was true
and now something very
different has happened.
That's the difference between
expectation and result.
Beds don't usually have lions in them.
You expect them not to have lions in them.
You pull down the bed.
Boom, there's a lion in it.
Situational irony.
Finally, it's perfect for lyin' on.
Now, Anna does not realize this,
but she is unwittingly punning
on the fact that there is
a lion on the Murphy bed.
So, this is verbal irony.
Because, in fact, there is
a lion lyin' on the bed.
So, there you have it.
Encapsulated in one ridiculous case,
here are all three
basic examples of irony.
So, situational irony, dramatic
irony, and verbal irony.
You can learn anything, David out.